mom's beautiful we love you counting on
star Mary Duggar has died the Duggar
family announced the sad news to their
shared Facebook page on Sunday sharing
the death of Jim Bob's mom with the
world quote we are so sad to share that
grandma Duggar Mary passed away Sunday
afternoon
June 9th 2009 teen Mary who is survived
by son JimBob her daughter Deanna 21
grandchildren and 13 great-grandchildren
was a real estate broker who often
appeared on the family's TLC shows 19
Kids and Counting
tonight the older girls are speaking at
a birthday party so I will have all the
younger children with me and counting on
well I think it's really neat being
close to the Duggar house just across
the field from them so it's gonna be a
it's gonna be a really neat experience
Jill Duggar took to Instagram to share
her own tribute sharing this pic of her
son's Israel and Samuel with Mary she
captioned the sweet shot quote she was
an amazing woman of God and such a great
example to so many she was a feisty
incredible woman who always took the
time to talk about Jesus with everyone
she knew Anna Duggar also posted about
the family's loss alongside several pics
of Mary with her six children quote what
an awesome woman of faith and such a
loving example of God's love joy Duggar
and her husband Austin posted about Mary
on their shared account writing she was
a strong woman role model godly
counselor and my favorite person to
watch The Price is Right show with she
is greatly loved and missed
[Music]
[Applause]